m
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bernard
bonjour nous avons voulu cette semaine
donner la parole à une minorité agréable
et intéressante
les poules piste monsieur cory zié
messieurs corrosive vous êtes depuis
1975 président des poules piste de
france 76 précisément oui et alors quel
est le but de votre association
c'est une excellente question je vous
remercie de me l'avoir posée là pfg te
dire l'association des bouddhistes de
france a été créé dans le but de mettre
en contact et de faire se rencontrer
aussi souvent que faire se peut les
françaises et les français qui aiment à
se mettre un poulpe sur la tête
et comment devient ampoules piste
excellente question
on devient poule piste on devient pour
le pis pas par besoin d'identité par
besoin de de se re connaître soi-même
par besoin de se reconnaître pour lutter
contre cette société et robotisée c'est
cela le moment est propice par besoin de
ce recueil tout est alors en dehors de
ce facteur de reconnaissance quels sont
les autres avantages du poulpe isme
c'est une excellente question il
ils sont vraiment multiples voyez-vous
par exemple l'été le poulpe est frais et
très agréable à porter en revanche
l'hiver il constitue un rempart très
très efficace contre toutes les
intempéries le froid la neige et puis
par ailleurs grâce à saluant ce naturel
le poulpe retient les pellicules les
pellicules disgracieuses dans la
prolifération sauvage pourrait nuire par
exemple au développement d'une idylle
mais on dit aussi que le poulpe isma des
effets bénéfiques sur la santé alors
qu'en est il exactement c'est une
excellente question je vous remercie de
me l'avoir posée c'est tout à fait exact
vous faites allusion j'imagine l'action
analgésiques du populisme en cas de
céphalées oui oui oui
alors si permis
les gens qui nous regardent ce soir
certains souffrent de maux de tête
migraine diverses qu'ils fassent
l'expérience suivante alors vous mettez
un poulpe sur la tête et vous absorbez
vous avez les deux aspirines et vous
verrez le résultat tout à fait
stupéfiant alors que si vous faites le
contraire
deux résultats nuls et puis alors enfin
le poulpe le poulpe est constitué un
excellent remède facile contre le bruit
oui qui est vice président et alors vous
aussi madame vous êtes poule piste
depuis toujours ou la non vous allez
rire mais jusqu'à l'âge de 25 quand
j'étais végétarienne authentique
puis j'ai rencontré georges l'un des
pionniers du tourisme et il vous a
converti non non il m'a toujours laissé
libre de mes opinions
sammonds lorsque nous allions au cinéma
ou bien au restaurant ou simplement que
quand nous étions invités chez des amis
j'avais l'impression qu'il était un peu
triste d'être le seul apporter un plus
sur la tête
et puis l'idée que le jour du mariage je
puisse arriver tête nue
je crois qu'il avait un petit peu honte
de moi j'ai cédé et vous ne le regrettez
pas c'est une excellente question je
vous remercie de la vieux reposer je
vais vous dire je ne pourrais même pas
supporter l'idée que je puisse vivre
sans un poulpe sur la tête
mais quelle explication donnez-vous à
cela mais c'est un animal très
affectueux on s'y attache terriblement
très affectueux et très obéissants
regard des sultans pas bougé
ah ouais non c'est impressionnant voilà
jeté doucement sultan doucement voilà
des animaux d'où une association
paisible et pourtant les poules piste
dérange puisqu'on continue à leur
refuser l'entrée des plages alors à ce
propos écoutons ce qu'a à dire la
présidente des noms poule piste de
france nous disons que le spectacle de
ces personnes qui se promènent sur nos
plages le tout à l'air est un spectacle
révoltant pour nos enfants et même pour
les adultes
en conséquence de quoi nous demandons
aux municipalités du littoral de france
de bien vouloir nous montrer ce qu'elles
ont dans leur pantalon en leur
interdisant les bords de mer vous
comprenez pourquoi
devant cette intolérance qui frise
l'apartheid nous demandons nous
demandons quoi nous demandons instamment
aux pouvoirs publics de nous réserver
des espaces où nous pourrons enfin nous
et battre et poulpe est librement parce
que c'est un droit
et parce que nous l'exigeons ça le
mélodieux c'est un excellent post
je vous remercie de m'avoir posé et bien
nous espérons que votre appel sera
entendu
la semaine prochaine nous vous parlerons
d'une autre minorité agréable et
intéressante
les rhinos rsistes à la semaine
prochaine
bonsoir et maintenant jocelyne et son
équipe ont testé pour vous je teste des
gestes c'est faux la nouvelle
bouillabaisse furent volées tu fais bon
fait bon mais il vaut mieux la dv avant
de m'en fous j'ai testé pour vous le
premier rasoir jetable avant usage
moi je veux bien j'ai testé pour vous le
lions du zoo de vincennes
c'est un mal
eh bien oui christian ici jean-jacques
flatte ou là qui vous parle en direct de
bruxelles
je me trouve précisément devant le
palais de l'europe où nous attendons
tous sous une petite pluie fine mais
pénétrante la sortie des ministres du
marché commun agricole qui sont réunis
tous ici depuis maintenant trois jours
vous le savez pour tenter ensemble de
sortir l'europe agricole de l'impasse
dans laquelle se trouve actuellement
mais alors je vous parle on me fait
signe et on me fait signe que l'un des
délégués
oui je crois que c'est l'un des délégués
du marché comme avec cole qui va sortir
oui c'est même le délégué français c'est
le délégué français c'est le délégué
français c'est monsieur que lamont
collard qui sort matin qui se présente
seul devant le sur le perron de du
marché du beurre
ce ministre là messieurs les micros
c'est là c'est non parce que d'habitude
si je fais le haut mesdames messieurs
après un déjeuner de travail extrêmement
positif avec mes collègues de l'europe
des 6 9 9
9 oui on va te dis c'est très simple
récapitulons il y avait là roberto hans
castaigne bill safri 4 et john rollins a
fait six autos et moi ça fait
9 on voit l'homme on va déjà et de
travail extrêmement positif avec mes
collègues de l'europe des neuf déjeuner
de travail qui a duré plus de cinq
heures et demi et qui est d'ailleurs un
des plus réussis que nous ayons fait
depuis six ans eh bien je suis en mesure
de vous dire aujourd'hui que tous les
problèmes de l'europe qu'ils soient
alimentaires agricoles vinicole ou
encore ceux du vin sans oublier ceux des
liqueurs et de ce qu'on nomme à tort le
pinard ont été abordés je tiens à redire
à tous et pessimiste qui voyait l'europe
agonisante voix remorque et bien je leur
dis et le redis elle est repartie
l'europe comme en 40 min que vous avez
abordé le problème des laitages
hollandais dans le mois force
ma femme est articulé bien parce qu'
est-ce que vous avez aujourd'hui le même
délit d'âge oui oui ça ils ont été
évoqués durant ce déjeuner de travail
je crois que cette fois monsieur van
houtte hervé qu'a compris la mimolette
ne passera pas moi j'ai repris 4 fois du
camembert ans le machin avec du beurre
breton et ça ne nous a pas impressionné
outre mesure que monsieur van houtte
ehrbeck pour se venger et but avec le
ministre danois de bouteille de schnaps
car la belgique violent l'allemagne et
moi même avons immédiatement répliqué en
visant neuf bouteilles de pommard
établissant ainsi l' équilibre vital au
sein de la communauté
le ministre
le problème des hormones dans la
volaille anglaise anglaise l'a écouté
alors ça va vous dire parce que personne
n'en a pris 1 lorsque le poulet au
porridge est arrivé là tout le monde
rien que la sauce déjà savaient leur
firent que les hormones yakin le
ministre allemand qui a eu le courage de
prendre une cuisse oui qui non non très
sincèrement il s'est contenté de
recracher en proposant que la grande
bretagne soit issu du marché commun vous
aborder des problèmes de limites de
pêche 2 et qui les limite de la pêche au
quai pour la langoustine monsieur dubois
la petite île de malte avec toute
évidence un jeu julien n'avait pas venu
je ne peux pas vous dire je sais et la
viande à écouter alors ça je tiens à le
répéter encore une fois j'espère que ce
sera la dernière il n'y a aucun problème
de viol dans le marché commun écouter
lorsqu'on mange avec un bon appétit et
un bon côtes du rhône qui peut me dire
la différence il ya entre un mouton
anglais une vache allemande ou encore
italiens qui sinon ceux qui veulent
casserait le rap up en jouant la carte
de la différence écoutez nous étions là
neuf ministres et je vous rappelle que
nous sommes des ministres spécialistes
nous étions là neuf ministres et bien
nous avons dégusté les viandes
aucun de nous n'a pu dire ni de quel
pays il de quel animal cette viande
provenait et tout ça pourquoi parce que
nous voulons une europe égale pour tous
même pour les animaux et pour les
animaux aussi
aulas passe à une très bonne proposition
du ministre l'ex-strasbourgeois qui
s'est tellement régalé avec le curry
d'agneau qu'il a proposé que l'a proposé
que l'aisne entre-temps le marché commun
ce à quoi nous avons tous dit d'accord à
condition que l'on supprime les crédits
pour la culture des choux de bruxelles
qu'on a tous trouvé mais qu'on a mangé
quand même eu égard et par politesse et
de politesse et déférence dans la ville
ou dans laquelle on se trouve à
bruxelles
à bruxelles on écoute et vous avez cieux
il est maintenant au moins
20h30 et je crois que je vais devoir
vous quitter car nous avons ce soir à
dîner de travail très important car je
vous rappelle que le très grave problème
du coupage des vins italiens et français
l'a pas encore été résolus cela risque
de nous emmener très tard dans la nuit
on y passera le temps qu'il faudra mais
on y arrivera
monsieur les lycées par action de la
suisse si vous faites rentrer là dedans
le marché commun est ce que le craignez
pas que la suisse après ce qui s'est
passé et 2012 accords d'evian ne puisse
pas et pour qui capable
ce mini c'est ce que vous pensez
direction de l'est de l'inde si jamais
au carreau au cas où l'un d'entre eux va
vraiment d'un marché commun au cas où
l'un d'entre eux dans leur fille de 9
ans évoque les réactions déjà suis
serein et nos femmes comme d'habitude ou
plus tard monsieur après un déjeuner de
travail extrêmement positif déjeuner de
travail qui a duré plus de cinq heures
et demie est allé plus réussi que nous
ayons fait depuis six ans eh bien je
suis en mesure de vous dire je vais déjà
non plus
non tous les problèmes de l'europe ils
soient alimentaires une école ou un mars
du vin ou encore le épinards et pinard
et pensez vous que pensez vous que la
suisse réagir à bien rentrer dans le
marché
l'inde est exclue au monde
ils ont exclu lundi des forces
américaines l'inde fait virer oui
combien convient de 2h02
[Musique]
c'était très dur parce que à la mi temps
je viens il s'est fait qui s'est fait
deux équipes de l'armée
bonsoir
semaine
h comme hésitations de
m
[Musique]
vous
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
je testais pour vous l'annuaire du
lot-et-garonne
c'est une honte j'ai testé pour vous les
yaourts aux fruits sans colorant il y en
a quand même un peu plus
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je m'appelle annette
j'ai 29 ans je sais pas conduire je fais
pas très bien ma cuisine je n'aime ni
lire ni aller au cinéma
alors attention je suis une bande de
sexualité de sensualité
les deux mélangés je t'attends toi
l'homme qui sera monde détonateur je
demande même pas de photo
[Musique]
c'était pendant l'horreur d'une profonde
nuit
ma mère jézabel devant moi s'est montré
comme on jour de sa mort pompeusement
part et par là les malheurs n'avait
pointe a battu sa fierté même elle avait
encore cet éclat emprunter dont elle eu
soin de peindre et donné son visage pour
réparer des ans l'irréparable outrage
aux matelles dix filles dignes de moi le
cruel dieu des juifs l'emportent aussi
sur toi mais tu me dis que pour me
tabasser
google est elle est partie la méchante
elle est partie par la voix si ça a été
dur ça juste colère a voulu que je
frappe alors qu'elle est atteint on sait
pas c'est le méchant la berline vous
frapper la fifa parce que cela met un
ciel un calleur la rattrape et j'espère
puisque apparemment elle est partie par
là
bon alors si je comprends bien monsieur
le duc de saxe cobourg pour vous on peut
carrément parler d' événement théâtral
de la saison absolument et je crois que
jamais guignols n'a été aussi loin dans
la nuit cette adaptation de le redire et
ses cidres et sin on va là je veux bien
laisser revenir enfin puisqu'on parle du
travail de levier parlons-en
c'est quand même très confus tout ça un
exemple au troisième acte est bien quand
jézabel sorte par là enfin vous souvenez
bon ben moi j'entendais des gens comme
ça qui dit qu'il n'était pas passé par
là alors que les agresseurs qui l'a
d'ailleurs moi même j'étais au bout d'un
moment je les dis je c'est là elle est
sortie par la non mais si je le dise
hélas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le prix léon mort visart destiné à
récompenser un admirateur de l'oeuvre de
les hommes envisagent a été décerné
comme chaque année à lyon mais visent à
maisons-laffitte émouvantes obsèques
hier matin maisons laffitte de l'éleveur
de chevaux
henri père chine le corbillard été tirée
par trois purs sangs caparaçonnés de
crêpe noir premier le 12 juin puis 3 2e
le 5 place yves du manoir troisième 6
hermione devant la menace d'un
déclenchement désormais imminent de la
troisième guerre mondiale
la traditionnelle foire aux jupons de
molinard sur la clope a été reporté au
16 août lors de la cérémonie d'ouverture
des jeux olympiques c'est le français
alain chabot qui portait la
traditionnelle flamme olympique
il a été transporté dans un état
désespéré à l'hôpital des grands brûlés
météo après dissipation des brumes
matinales le temps sera beau et chaud
sur l'ensemble ricardo montasser ses
rythmes cubains qui coache critique
aïe aïe aïe
[Musique]
aujourd'hui comment séparer devra jours
il est très important de bien savoir
séparer de brezina bien séparer de vrais
jumeaux
c'est la seule vraie différence entre
l'homme et la mer il faut jamais invité
deux vrais jumeaux un dîner mondain un
seul suffira largement de toute façon
comme ça il mangera deux fois moins et
puis lui dira deux fois moins de
banalités qui on avait invité son frère
vu qu'ils sont rigoureusement identiques
j'ai ici deux jours dans un premier
temps nous allons vérifier qu'il s'agit
de vrais deux jours où doivent
évidemment se ressembler trait pour
trait or que voyons nous nous voyons que
parmi ces deux jumeaux l'un des deux au
moins celui-ci ne ressemble pas du tout
à l'eau c'est donc un faux ok je suis un
faux jumeaux la honte m'envahit
[Applaudissements]
voici maintenant un vrai jour chez voici
deux sont deux vrais jumeaux dit
monozygotes c'est à dire qu'ils sont
tout à fait inséparables
nous sommes inséparables dans l'état
actuel de la recherche
nous savons que si l'un des deux vrais
jumeaux subi une douleur physique son
frère ressentira exactement la même
douleur et exactement au même existe un
moyen d'éviter de séparer devrait jouer
et l'ordre je demanderai à mme jeannine
jeanine le coulis qu'habite 14 rue
nationale
villeneuve saint georges dans le 93 3 de
bien vouloir cesser de touiller sa
mayonnaise northcott chine exprime c'est
extrêmement perturbant d'autant qu'il
s'agit d'une expérience très difficile à
réaliser
merci moi je disais donc il existait un
moyen très très pénibles pour séparer
deux vrais jumeaux mais regardez vous à
louis ii il sait pas jouer aux pierres
les époux
j'arrête
je suis seul ce soir arrête m'énerve je
suis seule fois
non d'un prochain entretien nous verrons
ensemble comment séparer les blancs des
jaunes
j'échangerais bien ma vie morne et
plates contre un amour à l'épreuve du
temps j'échangerais bien la banalité qui
m'entourent contre un amour vrai
j'échangerais bien ma solitude contre un
bonheur à deux et j'échangerais bien
aussi mon poste de radio contre une
sacoche pour manger le moteur oui c'est
un un transistor un appareil à piles
mais on peut aussi le brancher sur le
secteur là là on peut le brancher
lausanne
l'historien helvétique hier le vin est
formel davy crockett des pas mort de
vents forts à l'amour comme on le
croyait généralement mais derrière c'est
tout non je voudrais faire une grimace
oui je veux bien merci
[Musique]